bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
testa sirena che è questo gioco horror
bellissimo che è spopolato l'anno scorso
ma io lo faccio ho fatto un metro o la
torcia scarica dove l'hai comprata da
wish marche torcia è ma scusa va beh il
mio personaggio cammina e non può non ha
la tornare a chi non ho fatto niente
come è possibile che non sai corre non
sai illuminare la torcia non ho fatto
niente
e semplicemente ridicolo detto john a
sono io che l'alimento a io ce l'avevo
anch'io st torcia a casa mia a torino
una volta che lo schiaccia visto cosa si
alimentava ma non durava così poco la
batteria fa schifo sono ovviamente per
alimentare la torcia me la devo
alimentare nel mentre in questa e una da
gas station figo
bella roba della batteria dal touch è
così solo che dura veramente poco
ho trovato una mappa non ho capito cosa
devo trovare però nel dubbio vediamo se
riesco a entrare pick up da te va bene
fratture avevo trovato warning se senti
una sirena corri non avrà pietà l'unica
speranza fare piano è pregare
se non senti niente che dio abbia pietà
della tua anima non fidarti delle luci
di strada cosa c'è praticamente devo
andare dall'altra parte completamente di
dove sono arrivato completamente dalla
parte opposta impossibile
ok mi sono dovuto fermare inizio nou
dove il ragazzino è un altro giorno puoi
fare niente casa o addirittura mettono
le mette le chiamate e tipo il
centralino telefonico mobile che cazzo
ed io mi immagino questa cosa fosse
autorizzata ma non meno soli dato
comunque non riesco ho capito dove dove
devo andare prima che lo disorientarli
manco per sbaglio
no ragazzi 1 milione come faccio a
muovermi non posso muovermi proprio
madonna mia ragazzi via via via fuori
dalle balle
basta circumnaviga armi poi tanto non
sarà anch'esso sto andando giusto e con
la strada e con la strada a posto ora
devo solo trovare la ga station che sta
a metà tra il posto ma non è la strada
questo sono finito non devo mai fidarvi
delle luci della strada però qua devo
farlo se non sono la strada
ok dov'è la che ha steso eccoci ok
quella da gas station playstation sarà
mica questo possiamo dire 3d station
play park come effetto 3 il seno è
giusto siamo al trade park
devo trovare una tomba got you the move
highland park the kill bill romance
hauer rai non trovare le chiavi e lui ha
detto che ad avere già scritto cadavere
non vedo
non vedo niente non vedo niente tutta un
attimo più di una via completamente
nascosta vediamo se qua lorca trottola
ragazza una via nascosta sarà qualche ad
avere non lo so
nel dubbio entro perché l'unica via che
mi viene in mente unica proprio madonna
ma c'è chi si è inventato si sta roba
del siren ed è un'ansia terribile
eccolo eccolo il cadavere è vabbè ma lei
pensa fosse conciato peggio va bene un
grazie delle chiavi per un ragazzo
quell'affare deve averlo preso
ok cioè le cose rotte no ragazzi
teoricamente il capanno vorrebbe 6
all'agi però non ne sono completamente
sicuro perché non visto di orientare mi
sento dai fermo e quindi
non era un lampione e col abbiamo
pregato sto pregando sono ferme si
conferma sto pregando sono fermi sono
fregato maria madre di dio che dovrebbe
fare è sceso il tuo pronto
ok bene tutto a posto potresti spegnere
la soundboard per favorita ma il freddo
ci spostiamo ok c'è anche il puntino
meno ma reggono segna perché dopo un po
che non ci arrivi mette il continuo
secondo me perché ha visto non lo mette
subito ma non è che non ci arrivo perché
non ho capito dove non c'è più ora che
c'è quello e mezzo che doveva se corro
mimì in groppa ma scusami eh sì
ambulanza di toretto allora praticamente
dovrei essere arrivato spero di dio e
che non che funzioni la chiave perché a
quel punto spunta l'altro come ha fatto
sapere quello che sarebbe morto lì il
cadavere nel suo cadavere va beh non è
la scritta alpinista frase per prendere
per il culo
[Musica]
ok trova un aedo sarebbe una maniglia ma
come sono tutte ste cagate che sto
prendendo salve chi l'ha vista lei
ragazzi trovato un sacco di roma non so
come usarla dov'è lo zero
eccolo quindi segni vi do una macchina
addosso lui che è successo non uscire no
frate che non sto facendo niente io
questa rimaste dentro tutta la vita che
rifiuti la porta chiusa porta ancora
fuori dalla finestra francia la
cinematica che gioco pazzesco della sto
falso perché che azzolini ragazzi ma
orribile io rimango qua c'è una bomba
d'acqua sopra bagnarlo magari si sia
ruggini ce ne è uscito
io ci sono andato bene ok devo riparare
la pompa alla stazione per poi fare
benzina e correre qua c'è una tanica per
caso eccola ho trovato la tanica trovare
un mezzo che non so cosa sia
abbiamo tratto degli occhiali va bene lo
stesso non ho capito solassi un nodo
però non posso usare la tecnica lo
stesso ti prego non ho idea di dove sia
stonato a me lo dice lui è normale sono
melody riguarda se non me lo diceva lui
amerà sempre qua ma allora va a fan culo
però questo mi segna sempre la tanica
quindi niente non scherzava non equa no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
fatto niente sto pregando tornino
pregare
mia limonato no non l'avevo capito se
non lampione quando si aspetto mi sono
cagato nelle mutande che pirla finale va
bè ragazzi cero porca vacca c'ero quasi
speriamo che il prossimo da meglio
fateci sapere nei commenti ragazzi 7 di
consigli come l'ho giocata pure bene
porco demonio sapevo non guardavano
anche lampione discrete anche lei era
come se i ragazzi ci vediamo al prossimo
video
[Musica]